I wanted to acknowledge the devastating loss
of a dear friend and member of the marvel
studios family chadwick boseman was an immensely
talented actor and an inspirational individual
who affected all of our lives professionally
and personally his portrayal of t'challa the
black panther is iconic and transcends any
iteration of the character in any other
medium from marvel's past and it's for that
reason that we will not recast the character
however to honor the legacy that chad helped us
build through his portrayal of the king of wakanda
we want to continue to explore the world of
wakanda and all of the rich and varied characters
introduced in the first film writer director ryan
coogler is hard at work on the sequel now and
will bring the film to you in theaters july 8th
2022 we've got a lot in store at marvel studios
and disney plus is key to the interconnection and
expansion of the mcu it will be home for both our
future films and our series for years and years
to come since marvel first joined disney back
in 2009 bob iger's been the biggest champion
of the work that we do none of this would have
been possible without his support so it is now my
pleasure to turn things back over to bob thank you
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel black panther 2 movie video obviously kevin
feige has been talking a lot about what's going
on with the new version of black panther 2 that
ryan coogler is working on right now so i'll
explain what he said and what it means about
the future of that franchise what he's talked
about the characters what it's going to explore
how the story has changed and how that's tied up
in the future of the mcu with the other movies
like fantastic four in avengers 5. so if you're
new to the channel we're doing a giveaway for
disney plus memberships because of Wandavision
starting all you have to do to enter is just
be a subscriber and let me know what you want them
to do with the future black panther movies because
of course there will be more sequels probably
the biggest thing that he talks about there the
biggest revelation is that they will not recast
chadwick boseman as t'challa so there obviously
will be more black panthers he doesn't say that
they won't have more black panthers he's saying
that they won't have more t'challa's they won't
bring in another actor and in a separate video
recently when he was doing Wandavision interviews
he also addressed that they wouldn't have a cg
version of chadwick boseman they're not going
to do any kind of star wars rise of skywalker
carrie fisher situation where they try to rework
a digital version of them into scenes with other
actors chadwick boson will continue to be an
important part of the story of black panther ii
very critical to what's actually happening
with the plot but just not in the way that
you expected before then kevin feige's other big
revelation is that the story will focus more on
the world of wakanda itself so when the way the
first black panther movie in avengers infinity
war sort of gave us the cliffs notes version of
wakanda we learned a little bit about it there's
so many different groups different religions
different fighting forces all vying for control
within wakanda we just saw like a brief taste of
that when t'challa was taking the throne during
the first black panther movie like are there any
challengers then umbaku steps up if you haven't
read any of the black panther comics or you've
only read some of them or it's been a long time
there was actually more recent run i think it
was volume six of black panther the tahana kasi
coats did that was a more complex look at the
structure in the inner workings of wakandan
society so it's actually probably a good place
to go to just to get the deep dive into wakanda
you may have also seen the recent rumors that
doctor doom might be the main villain for black
panther 2 because there is a long rich history
between doctor doom in the world of wakanda and
black panther character in the comics as well
as a really deep connection to the fantastic
four with the black panther character in fact if
you're not a big comic book reader in general the
black panther character debuted for the first
time in the comics in fantastic four number 52
and during that big disney plus presentation that
kevin feige did for all the different shows in the
upcoming movies right after he dropped this teaser
for what's going on during black panther 2 he did
the big revelation about their new version of the
fantastic four movie so he's mentioning new mcu
fantastic four in black panther 2 in the same
breath meaning that those movies will probably
share some sort of connection at least on
a surface level even if the new fantastic
four movie doesn't come out till a couple movies
after black panther 2. because black panther 2 is
firmly summer 2022 and we're probably not going
to see fantastic four until 2023 maybe like a
year later the big connection between doctor doom
and black panther character is that just like a
lot of other big marvel villains he wanted their
vibranium there was this big arc in the comics
called doom war where he basically takes his army
of doombots and invades wakanda eventually takes
it over and also tries to hijack black panther's
connection to boss the panther goddess where a
lot of their more cosmic abilities come from he
tries to steal the powers of black panther's god
it is the most doctor doom thing that you could
possibly do that's one of the beauties of the
doctor doom character is that he's both a man of
science and a man of magic so you could actually
put him in a movie like doctor strange like doctor
strange versus doctor doom it would be really
awesome they also have a long history of teaming
up in the comics or you could even put them up
against one of the more science-based avengers
like iron man obviously iron man in the present
day of the mcu no longer around but the fantastic
four obviously very technologically inclined group
the other big reason why that doom war doctor
doom storyline is a big deal is because that's
also the black panther arc where shuri became a
version of the black panther taking the mantle
from t'challa briefly the whole connection
between black panther and the fantastic four
is that way back in fantastic four number 52 they
get an invitation from black panther to come to
wakanda and just see this mystery land that nobody
has ever been to before when they arrived they
wind up fighting black panther because obviously
this is comics so if you show up with a brand new
character of course they're going to fight before
they become friends they eventually chill out and
t'challa reveals that he was just testing them
and asked them here to help him deal with ulysses
claw who's come to try and steal their vibranium
so obviously we've already done ulysses claw in
the black panther and the other marvel movies but
the whole concept of vibranium is still a really
important thing in the background one of the most
precious resources on planet earth just because
we made it through the whole killmonger adventure
with him trying to send vibranium weapons all over
the earth to arm militias to just sort of take
over the planet and we made it through avengers
end game doesn't mean that everybody in the mcu
is going to stop wanting vibranium also with the
death of black panther you also have a question of
who's going to take the throne most people would
think that shuri is going to become the next black
panther because technically she's his successor
she's the next in line for the throne but anybody
in wakanda can challenge for the throne so umbaku
could challenge for the throne if he wants and
there's no way that shuri is going to defeat him
without her technology and if you've seen their
fights they depower themselves you can't use any
special vibranium weapons it basically has to be a
knock down drag out fight old school style there's
no way that shuri could beat m'baku in a fight
like that there was some news about casting one
of the other minor villains he could wind up being
white tiger or one of the other big black panther
villains there are a number of different religious
cults that all worship different gods inside
wakanda the panther cult is just the main one that
black panther worships that's their connection to
boss the panther god doctor strange is probably
one of the most important characters during
marvel phase 4 because of all this multiverse and
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness is kind of
the culmination of all that you have characters
like doctor voodoo but there's also people within
wakanda that practice different kinds of magic
that are a little bit different from the magic
that doctor strange practices like they're more
like shamans but it's the same idea different
kinds of magic inside the mcu and if doctor doom
is going to wind up being one of the villains that
would be amazing if he was they could also start
to set up the idea of the cabal in the background
even though they're more like the evil version
of the illuminati and we haven't got to the
illuminati in the mcu yet but now that we have the
x-men and the fantastic four characters they can
actually do that eventually strangely enough
nobody asked kevin feige any questions about
illuminati but they did ask him about avengers 5
and he's like oh yeah that's a pretty cool name
avengers maybe we'll use it again for some movies
like hell yeah we're gonna do more avengers movies
avengers movies for disney are kind of like
licenses to print money so there's no way
they're ever going to stop making avengers movies
the whole idea though with the black panther
franchise is that before chadwick boseman passed
away he was going to become one of the linchpins
of the mcu going forward into marvel phase 4 phase
5 through all the x-men the fantastic four stuff
all the bigger avengers secret war stuff down the
line he was probably one of their most important
characters next to spider-man they'll be filming
the black panther 2 movie before too long so
we'll hear more news about castings and who the
villains are going to be and how they're going to
invoke all these x-men characters because around
the time the black panther drops around the time
of the fantastic four movie that's when we're
going to see the transition from marvel phase
4 to marvel phase 5 in marvel phase 5 is really
where you'll see the rebooted version of the x-men
start running around a lot but i am expecting
them to introduce a lot of fantastic four stuff
easter eggs and x-men easter eggs mutants before
that especially starting in the Wandavision series
my full Wandavision episode videos are going to
start posting on friday it'll be a weekly show so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those everyone let me
know in the comments though what do you just
want them to do with the black panther character
and their franchise going forward if we have all
this big fantastic four and x-men stuff spinning
up into secret wars eventually while you wait for
everything everyone click here for that brand new
wandavision episode one scene and click here
for that brand new marvel fantastic four teaser
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!